What is in protein powder that you don't have that you don't it to have in
don't like to have in it okay so what is it in protein powder that you want to
have a minimum of and that is glutamine so glutamine is an amino acid so
protein powder by definition is going to have amino acids in it that's what a
protein powder is has amino acids in it so there's different concentrations of
different amino acids depending on the type of protein powder some protein
powders are made are formulated with the idea to help heal the gut so some
protein powders are formulated with different ideas different conditions of
mine many of the protein powders out there are formulated with the idea to help
heal the gut well glutamine is an amino acid which is really good to help heal
the gut well why does glutamine help heal the gut because glutamine works
better than most amino acids to help stimulate growth so when you're talking
about healing gut cells you want you know rapid growth so they're going to
turn over and you'll get a new gut cell growing and it'll be healthy and you're
going to help heal the gut well you don't want to use glutamine or you're
going to get glutamine in your diet because it's in all proteins you need any
proteins even plan proteins will still have glutamine but you don't want to take a
product that has a whole bunch of glutamine because you don't want to stimulate
a bunch of growth so you don't use protein powders if you have cancer you
don't use protein powders that have a lot of glutamine in it usually it's it's
fairly easy to see a lot of protein powders don't show the exact
concentration of each amino acid some say a mix so it's a little bit harder to to
see sometimes you have to go on the company's website to see you know what the
concentration of the amino acids are but you want something that's relatively
lower in glutamine or it doesn't have excess glutamine compared to the other
amino acids that's the biggest thing so you want one that's not was not
formulated with healing the gut in mind